ان تحرز هدفا في المونديال فذلك انجاز
كبير لكن ان تكون هداف كاس العالم فهذا هو
التاريخ من الهدفون التاريخيون في
المونديال
ابن المنشقت جارد مولر شارك في نسختين من
المونديال سجل فيهما 14 هدفا في الاولى
عام 1970 بالمكسيك احرز 10 اهداف لكنها لم
تشفع لفريقه الذي حل ثالثا في البطوله في
النسخه التاليه احرز اربعه اهداف احدها في
المباراه النهائيه في مرمى هولندا ليتوج
بالذهب على ارضه ووسط جمهوري
الظاهره البرازيلي رونالدو شارك في
المونديال اربع مرات متتاليه الاولى عام
1994 التي توج فيها باللقب من مقاعد
البدلاء ولم يشارك في اي مباراه في نسخه
1998 سجل اربعه اهداف صيدا بفريقه الى
المباراه النهائيه التي خسرها لصالح فرنسا
اصحاب الارض والجمهور في مونديال كوريا
واليابان 2002 عاده سامبا الى منصه
التتويج هذه المره وضع الظاهره رونالدو
بصمته بثمانيه اهداف
اختتم مشاركته الموندياليه بنسخه 2006
التي اكتفى فيها بثلاثه اهداف واكتفى
فريقه بربع النهائي
على خطى مواطنه جارد مولر انطلاقه
البرازيلي رونالدو
[موسيقى]
عام 2006 ليصبح الهداف التاريخيه لمنتخب
بلاده والهدافه التاريخيه للمونديال
هل تتذكر احد هذه الاهداف من هو هدافك
المفضل في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]